this video is brought to you by fin
Sarah watches quality handcrafted
watches at affordable prices check out
the full range of these things of in
Sarah watches comm /bi graphics more on
them in a bit if you're a film buff you
should be familiar with the early Soviet
movie Battleship Potemkin and its iconic
scene of a pram rolling down a
staircases soldiers shoot down
protesters the film is centred around
the Russian Revolution of 1905 and
directed by cinematic legend Sergei
Eisenstein Eisenstein would later direct
October a retelling of that other
uprising the successful one the Russian
Revolution of 1917 this film features
our protagonist of today Alexander
Kerensky depicted as a pompous poor
man's Napoleon his image juxtaposed with
that of a mechanical peacock karinski
was portrayed as a clear symbol of
artificial vanity this on flattering
portrayal it reflects the Bolsheviks
opinion of Kerensky who in modern times
has been relegated to a mere footnote in
the early history of the Soviet Union
yet despite the Bolsheviks perception
and Eisenstein's clever montage
techniques Alexander Kerensky was a
revolutionary he had a crucial role in
the overthrow of the Tsar's he had been
a central figure in the earlier
revolution of February 1917 when he had
led the provisional government and
sought to instill democracy in Russia so
did he deserve the pollow legacy why
let's find out in today's video about
the man himself Alexander Kerensky the
early revolutionary
Alexander Kerensky was born on May the
fourth 1881 in the town of simbirsk
this town is now known as uh leonov's
CAFTA another famous fellow who was born
eleven years later Vladimir Ulyanov
better known as Lenin Alexander's father
was a teacher and director of the local
gymnasium the same place that Lenin had
studied the Kerensky's and the early
novels were in fact on friendly terms
and belonged to the same middle-class
intellectual circle in 1899 Alexander
completed his studies at the gymnasium
graduating with a gold medal for
distinction he had the reputation of
being a polite and smart young man more
importantly he was a skilled dancer and
even a gifted actor after high school
Kerensky enrolled at the law faculty of
some petersburg university graduating in
1904 during the same year he married the
daughter of a general olga Baron of skya
I'm sure he seduced with his smooth
dance moves Alexandra and Olga later had
two sons my Dino v was the year that
everything changed for the young
Kerensky Sunday the 22nd of January
became known as a Bloody Sunday one of
too many bloody Sundays in human history
Russian society was gripped in unrest
due to the unpopularity of the
government's and the debacle of the
ongoing russo-japanese war crowds had
gathered for a peaceful demonstration
outside the Winter Palace in some
petersburg when the army and police
opens fire killing and injuring around a
thousand people the revolution of 1905
continued with the mutiny of the
battleship potemkin in june which
inspired the film that we mentioned
earlier the resulting riots they were
quashed by troops on the Tsar's orders
on the 30th of october saw nicholas ii
issued the October manifesto which
promised limited civil liberties and an
elected parliament the Duma in the same
month Kerensky had begun his career as a
political lawyer at a trial in Toulon in
present-day Estonia he defended the
peasants who had ransacked a local
aristocrats mansion Kerensky continued
to defends revolutionary activists in
court and joins the aid committee for
the victims of Bloody Sunday this
revolutionary fervor was made clear when
he joins the socialist revolutionary
party becoming the editor of their
newspaper burov ethnic or fourth under
the Thunderbird was go under Kerensky's
management's it increased its
circulation but attracted the attention
of the authorities along the way the
newspaper became an object of police
repression the 8th issue was confiscated
and on the 21st of December Kerensky's
flat was searched the police found
incriminating evidence leaflets
advertising the armed uprising
organization which was considered to be
a terrorist outfit
Kerensky he was held in custody until
April 1906 he was released due to a lack
of evidence but the Tsarist police sent
him on a forced vacation - as Becca Stan
he went with his wife and their
one-year-old son
Oleg in autumn 1906 he was allowed to
return to some Petersburg where he
resumed his activity as a popular lawyer
famous for his erasure II skills at his
political trials in 1910 Kerensky was
the chief defender of the Turkestan
social revolutionary organization
accused of staging arms anti-government
acts the trial went well for the
defendants as the young lawyer succeeded
in preventing any death sentences in
1912 he also shined as the defender of a
group of - knacks Armenian activists who
were accused of terrorist acts these
trials vaulted Kerensky into the
political stage of his era he grew in
status and in 1912 he was elected deputy
of the fourth state duma from the
trudeau vicky or labor group he soon
became the factions leader and joined a
freemason society to unite the anti
Tsarist forces striving for the
democratic renewal of Russia his
popularity grew even more when he
exposed Roman malinovski and early
Bolshevik leader as an undercover agent
of the arc Rana the Tsar's secret police
in Kerensky the young labor movements
that founds an effective leader a vocal
critic of the government and one of the
best speakers on the left by the time of
World War one breaking out in August of
1914 Kerensky was the Dumas
highest-profile radical as well as one
of the few to oppose Russia's entrance
into the conflict but in late 1915
Kerensky adopted a lower profile at the
duma as his health that declines because
of a kidney disease his condition it
continued to deteriorate and in April
1916 karinski had to go to Sweden to
have a
kidney removed according to his grandson
Stephen he was almost constantly on
intravenous morphine for the rest of his
life Kerensky returns the capital in the
summer which had now been rechristened
as petrograd his stance on the worid had
changed he was now fully committed to
Russia's participation in the war as a
means to oppose German militarism none
of that could get nicholas ii off the
hook though is karinski continued his
personal attacks on the tsar the monarch
had taken personal command of the Armed
Forces in September of 1915 something he
really should have left to the
professionals
now everybody had turned against him and
is pretty poor command skills by the end
of 1916 Kerensky he was publicly calling
for the Tsar's abdication in February of
1917 Kerensky left labour to rejoin the
socialist revolutionary party he called
again for the removal of nicholas ii
which prompted Tsarina Alexandra to
demands that he be hanged as a traitor
there are family cave at first the
pressure was too much and the Tsar
abdicated on March the 13th a
provisional government was formed under
Prince George Lavrov who appointed
Kerensky as Minister of Justice the
cabinet was now ruled by the
constitutional Democrats or cadet party
in the tense alliance with the more
radical left the energetic Alexander
immediately abolished capital punishment
and introduced other reforms freedom of
the press the abolition of ethnic and
religious discrimination and he even set
plans for universal suffrage the
provisional government also had no
intention to quit the war at this stage
Foreign Minister Millia cough sent a
note to the ontong to inform them of
this policy when the note became public
the Bolsheviks the Soviets of the
soldiers and tens of millions of
Russians were not amused and that's
putting it very mildly that disastrous
war had rallied the people against the
Tsar ins now the provisional government
wanted to continue the fighting in April
the crowds were marching under the
banner down with a provisional
government naturally Millia cough was
forced to resign the same fate befell
two war minister gu cough who was
promptly replaced by the charismatic
Kerensky now a war minister at the young
age of just 36 Kerensky
off the europe's eastern front the
former pacifist roused the troops in a
series of emotional speeches appealing
to them to continue the fighting with
his new powers Kerensky appointed
legendary general Brusilov as the
commander-in-chief of the Russian army
On June the 18th the war Minister he
announced a new offensive the July
offensive was an attack on the
austro-hungarians in Galician and it
initially was a great success but in a
repeat of many similar operations in
World War one low morale and poor supply
lines they slowed down the advance which
was then stopped completely by German
reinforcements meanwhile the Bolshevik
protests against the war they forced
Prince lavalla to resign as the prime
minister on the 8th of July he was
replaced by the unstoppable and still
popular
Kerensky Ariadna took over a member of
the constitutional Democrat Party
commented Kerensky was perhaps the only
member of the government who knew how to
deal with the masses since he
instinctively understood the psychology
of the mob there in layers power and the
main source of his popularity Kerensky's
popularity extended outside of the
Russian borders the British and the
Americans were great supporters as well
Mansfield Smith coming head of mi6
arranged for his government to receive
1.2 million dollars in today's money and
the Americans sent a similar gift the
spymaster also sends an asset to keep an
eye on Kerensky and ensure that he did
not sign an armistice with the central
Empire's mad asset was none other than
celebrated author William Somerset
Maugham who back then was on the mi6
payroll the novelist wrote the long and
short of it was that I should go to
Russia and keep the Russians in the war
despite Kerensky's best efforts the
Russian army was melting away after the
failed offensive hundreds of thousands
deserted using their weapons to seize
land from the aristocracy and forcibly
redistributed from this moment on
Kerensky would execute one bad move
after the other which would eventually
lead to the rise of Lenin and the
Soviets but just before we get into
those bad moves something that would be
an excellent move for your style and
that would be Vince Aero watch then
Sarah creates exceptionally crafted
timepieces fair prices these watches
they're great-looking they're certainly
not that minimalistic look that you know
a lot of modern watches go for instead
they've got this really bold style
whether you go
this is a chrono s this is a rogue but
there's a full range of them at the
website link below what I like about
this is it's not that minimalistic style
it's not that kind of watch that looks
like every other watch that no one ever
notices or cares about these watches get
attention because they're bold they look
good the one I'm wearing now like I said
is a chrono s but for this one this
rogue
I basically wore this for most of the
summer because it's got this rubber
strap on here which I find a little
better in the heat because I tend to
sweat a little bit and the leathers not
so great for that but autumn has come
winter is coming and I'm back on the
leather strap which to be honest is my
preference but you know different uh
different styles for different people
Vince era have over 18,000 five-star
reviews so it's really hard to go wrong
the attention to detail is great I love
this clasp thing on the back just I know
this isn't exactly the most exciting
feature of watch but I like you're just
really Clips open neatly and shuts just
like that you can see I got the tiniest
wrists in the world with that's all guys
around my wrist like I say these aren't
boring minimalist watches they are
unforgettable
great-looking watches but they still
keep things classy so go check out the
full range of interior watches com
forward slash biographic you can also
use the code biographic song check out
for a special discounts and let's get
back to the video bad move number one
spark and military coup to regain
control of the army Kerensky fart brew
Slavens appointed general kornél Ava's
commander-in-chief korolev did not share
Kerensky social and democratic views in
fact he had plans to restore the death
penalty for soldiers and even to
militarize the factories which did not
please the Prime Minister when Kerensky
refused Colonel Eoff threatened a
military coup he was dismissed before
ordering an army contingents to take
control of Petrograd Kerensky was in
danger the only ones who could help him
were his uneasy allies the Bolsheviks
with their Red Guards Lenin agreed to
help but he made it clear that they
would be fighting against corner love
and not for Kerensky an important
distinction bad move number two arm your
rivals
the request for help gave the Bolsheviks
a good reason to arm and enlist a force
of 25,000 men they fortified Petrograd
ready for a bloody battle but it turned
out that this wasn't needed a delegation
of Red Guards went to meet with Colonel
lofts troops which were apparently
more chilled than Kerensky expected the
regular army refused to attack that
regard and Korolev was arrested bad move
number three pick the wrong allies
Kerensky who by now had a CV as long as
the Volga River hopped to another prime
position supreme commander of the
Russian army backed by British and
American gold the leader continued with
the war effort which dented his
popularity on the 8th of October
Kerensky attempted to regain some
left-wing support by forming a new
coalition but he arguably picked the
wrong allies he invited a majority of
mensheviks and socialist revolutionaries
while the power within the left had
shifted towards Lenin's Bolsheviks at
Kerensky's own earlier request the
Bolsheviks now controlled a formidable
force of 25,000 armed militiamen
Kerensky would not be able to reassert
his authority to be fair to Kerensky he
was in a very difficult position from
the left he was threatened by the
Bolsheviks hostile to the continuation
of the war and his support of the
Mensheviks
from the right his provisional
government could still fall to the
schemes of Korolev who at least
according to Leon Trotsky could count on
support from old Foreign Minister mili
akov on October the 31st 1917
Kerensky summoned agent Somerset Maugham
with a desperate request he had to take
an urgent secret message to British
Prime Minister David Lloyd George
appealing for weapons and ammunition
Baum was unimpressed by Kerensky
describing him as a defeated man his
personality had no magnetism he gave no
feeling of intellectual or physical
vigor mom set off immediately and two
days later he was at 10 Downing Street
after the agent told the Prime Minister
what Kerensky wanted Lloyd George
replied I can't do that I'm afraid I
must bring this conversation to an end I
have a cabinet meeting I must go to in
modern political parlance we could
assert that Kerensky had been totally go
stood by his supposed allies back in
Petrograd the Bolsheviks had already
started to seize power this was the
first week of November for most of
Europe but to the Russians it was still
October hence the October Revolution
this is because Russia still used the
Julian calendar as opposed to the
Gregorian calendar and therefore they
lagged thirteen days behind
on the 7th of November Kerensky was
certain that the Bolsheviks were about
to seize the capital and he decided to
flee a story he began circulating about
Kerensky's escape but there is no
confirmation it goes like this
apparently he changed into a woman's
dress either in a nurse or servants
uniform and forced his way into a car
belonging to the u.s. embassy because
his car had the American flag on it
Kerensky easily passed all Bolshevik
checkpoints later that day the Red Guard
storms the Winter Palace and arrested
Kerensky's cabinet the only troops loyal
to Kerensky were the woman's death
battalion some young military cadets and
a detachment of cossacks after his
escape the deposed leader tried to get
the support of the Russian army on the
Eastern Front considering that this was
the same army he had forced into a
failed offensive resulting in mass
desertions they politely declined his
invitation do start a civil war
Kerensky was more successful in rallying
local troops from the northern front
they with them he marched towards
Petrograd on the 13th of November on his
way to the capital Kerensky led some
cossack troops into the barracks of
sukhoi a silo a former soros residence
south of Petrograd John Rietz American
journalist and author of the ten days
that shook the world described yet
another bad move and if you're counting
that would be bad move number four
alienate all military support Kerensky
entered the town riding a white horse at
the head of the cossacks at 7:00 in the
morning he sent word to the local rifle
regiments who lay down their arms
the soldiers replied that they would
remain neutral but they would not disarm
Kerensky gave them ten minutes to comply
this angered the soldiers who had been
governing themselves for eight months in
an independent Soviet a few minutes
later cossack artillery opens fire on
the barracks killing eight men read
wrote from that moment there were no
more neutral soldiers in Sequoyah
Kerensky could have used a well-trained
infantry regiment for what happened next
when Kerensky's loyalists march towards
Petrograd they numbered a mere six
hundred on their way they clashed with
five thousand Bolshevik troops led by
Leon Trotsky at the Battle of Port Cove
oh and this can really be considered the
beginning of the Russian Civil War
Trotsky easily won the engagement
putting an end to any attempt of armed
counter insurgency by Kerensky
in June 1918 Alexander Kerensky
disguised as a Serb officer left Russia
ready to embark on talks to organize a
counter-revolution during the one and a
half years of his exile Kerensky lived
in Britain mainly in the countryside
where living costs are lower later he
lived first in Prague ins then in Paris
where he contributed to various Russian
language newspapers editing denis and
novorossiya while in france he took part
in the inconsequential
inviting intrigues which plagued the
Russian exile community many exile
nostalgic of Tsarist rule had a deep
disdain for Kerensky once Russian women
having noticed him in the street in
Paris said to her Charles look Tanya
here is the man who ruined Russia the
Russian civil war between the red and
white factions was raging but it was
impossible for Kerensky to provide full
support to either side while he opposed
the Bolsheviks Kerensky did not trust
the white movement as he considered its
leadership too close to general kornél
of his old enemy in 1939 Alexander and
Olga Kerensky they got divorced and in
the same year he married former
Australian journalist Lydia Tritton when
the Germans occupied France in June of
1940 Kerensky and Lydia they fled to the
US where he resumed his activities as a
journalist and writer when Hitler
attacked the Soviet Union in June 1941
Kerensky offered his support to Stalin I
don't really know what type of answer he
was expecting but what he got was
absolutely logical he was totally
ghosted undeterred Kerensky established
radio transmissions to the USSR to
support the military effort after the
war he organized the union for Russia's
liberation presumably to restore a less
extremist regime in Russia but this did
not achieve any results when his wife
Lydia fell terminally ill in 1945 he
took her to Brisbane Australia and they
lived with her family until her death in
February 1946 he then returned to the
States living in both New York and a
Stanford University in California where
he taught Russian history on April the
24th 1970 karinski was admitted into
hospital in New York to recover from a
broken elbow and a pelvis sustained
after a fall at age 89 he did not
recover and on the 11th of June he died
of heart disease or cancer depending on
the sources even after his dying moments
this was a man who would
elicit strong reactions according to his
grandson there were some nurses in the
hospital of Russian origin and they
refused to touch him because they held
him responsible for starting the
revolution the local Russian Orthodox
Church refused to bury him as they
considered him to be a freemason and the
man behind Tsarist Russia is full the
local sir Botha Doc's Church also
refused to bury him his body it was
moved to London and buried at Putney
Vale Cemetery in London where he had
spent the very first part of his exile
and where his son's lived
[Music]
for 12 years Alexander Kerensky had been
a skilled lawyer a brilliant orator and
a well rounded politician who at a very
young age had covered many important
posts his moderate democratic socialism
while calling for the abolition of the
czars rule was needed balancing elements
for the Bolshevik excesses and yet
because of what he did in only four
months from July to October 1917 he
would be shunned by revolutionaries and
reactionaries alike mocked for his
supposedly
Napoleonic ambitions and generally
portrayed as a failure
some historians even believe that rather
than fearing a military coup by his
enemy kornel off Kerensky was actually
manipulating the general to create his
own dictatorship as a countermeasure his
limited inquiries into corner lobs
failed bid sparked suspicions that he
may have had authoritarian intentions
perhaps the reason for Kerensky's
failure in government was best explained
by British politician and journalist
Morgan Phillips price in the Manchester
Guardian on the 19th of April 1917 he
wrote the governments of Kerensky fell
before the Bolshevik insurgents because
it had no supporters in the country the
bourgeois parties and the generals and
the staff disliked it because it would
not establish a military dictatorship
the revolutionary democracy lost faith
in it because after eight months it had
neither given lands to the peasants nor
established state control of industries
nor advanced the cause of the Russian
peace program in other words Kerensky
was caught between two opposing factions
that were held together by only a common
enemy the rule of tsar nicholas ii in an
attempt to keep them together Kerensky's
bad moves had alienated all potential
support while arming his most motivated
rivals Lenin and Trotsky the February
revolution had led to the October
Revolution which led to the Soviet Union
the longest-running totalitarian state
in Europe and it also led to the cold
war it begs the question what could have
Russia and the rest of the world's been
at Kerensky just made a few different
choices so that's all for today please
do smash that like button subscribe to
this channel as normal also why not
check out our sister channel it's called
Geographics if you enjoy these
biographies you'll probably like that
channel it's very similar to this one
just about places rather than people so
subscribe to that there's a link below
and thank you for watching
[Music]
you